[Zene]
az egyik nagy felfedezése az életemnek
az volt amikor rá kellett jönnöm hogy
valóban léteznek alapelvek egyszerre
volt ez a felfedezés hihetetlenül
izgalmas és egyszerre borzasztó izgalmas
volt hiszen végre a kaotikus életem már
nem tűnt olyan kaotikusnak ugyanis ez
azt jelentette hogy vannak szabályok
amelyeket képes vagyok megérteni és nem
csak tehetetlenül bolyongok a világban
ahol ide-oda dobálnak majd a hullám
egyszerre viszont borzasztó is volt
ugyanis hogyha vannak szabályok akkor
nekem kell megismernem őket és
betartanom mert ha nem teszem akkor a
felelősséget is én kell vállaljam mert
mindennek amit teszek vagy mondok vagy
éppen nem teszek és nem mondok a
következményét én kell vállaljam a
navigátor podcast célja is ezeknek az
alapelveknek a keresése viszont az egy
hosszú formátom ahol különböző
érdeklődésű emberekkel beszélgetek ennek
a műsornak viszont az a célja hogy egy
desztilláltabb rövidebb változat legyen
ahol igyekszem egy-egy alapelvet külön
bemutatni és beszélni róla egyfajta
tananyagnak szánom azok számára akik
hozzám hasonlóan keresik az alapelveket
az életben és át akarják alakítani a
saját életüket aki a legtöbbet fog
tanulni ebből az pontosan én leszek
hiszen veletek együtt fogom keresni
ezeket az alapelveket és azáltal hogy
igyekszem szavakba önteni őket én magam
is mélyebben meg fogom érteni azért hogy
a csatornát önfenntarthatóvá tudjam
tenni úgy döntöttem hogy elindítok egy
navigátor közösséget a patreonon is ahol
támogatni tudjátok ezt a kezdeményezést
cserébe a támogatásotokért exkluzív
videókat készítek minden alapelvhez
amelyben részletesen átveszem hogy
hogyan lehet ezt praktikusan a
mindennapi személyes életben alkalmazni
legyél szülő szakember vagy éppen
cégvezető ezek az alapelvek ugyanúgy
érvényesek mindenkire mert milyenek is
az alapelvek kezdjünk is el beszélni
magukról az alapelvekről az első
epizódban egy konkrét példát is hozok rá
mégpedig a növekedés alapelvéről fogunk
[Zene]
beszélni az alapelvek univerzálisak
vagyis kultúrától nyelvtől és társadalmi
osztálytól függetlenek ugyanúgy
érvényesek indiában oroszországban
amerikában vagy bárhol máshol a világon
független attól is hogy valaki gazdag
vagy szegény környezetben él mert ezek
az elvek nem társadalmi vagy anyagi
helyzethez kötöttek az alapelvek
időtlenek igazak voltak több 1zer évvel
ezelőtt is igazak most is és igazak
lesznek a jövőben is nem tőlünk függenek
nem tudunk ellenük tenni nem tudjuk őket
befolyásolni figyelmen kívül hagyhatjuk
őket de akkor is hatással vannak az
életünkre az alapelvek egyszerűek
maguktól értetődőek nem kell hozzá sem
műveltnek sem különösen intelligensnek
lenni hogy megértsük őket sőt néha
pontosan a tudásunk áll az útjába annak
hogy igazán felfogjuk őket az ar rogáns
intellektus az amelyik azt mondja hogy
léteznek kivételek az alapelvek alól
amelyik folyamatosan lázad és nem akarja
elfogadni ezeket az elveket ha viszont
elfogadjuk hogy vannak alapelvek akkor
azt is el kell fogadnunk hogy léteznek
ideálok és az ideál mindig bíró is
egyben mert megmutatja hogy hol térünk
el tőle és hol nem felelünk meg neki
ahhoz viszont hogy az alapelveket
elfogadjuk és elkezdjünk aszerint élni
két dologra lesz szükségünk alázatra és
bátorságra alázatra hogy belássuk ezek
az alapelvek függetlenek az én
akaratomtól ha eltérünk tőlük akkor
nekünk kell változnunk mert az
alapelveket nem tudjuk megváltoztatni
bátorságra mert a környezetünk néha
bolondnak néz majd minket ha
ragaszkodunk ezekhez az elvekhez ez a
sorozat tehát a bátor és alázatos
emberek sorozata lesz vegyük is az első
alapelvet a növekedés alapelvét
minden természetes rendszer fejlődése
folyamatos egy gyermek nem tud
megtanulni járni ha előtte nem tanul meg
kúszni és nem fog tudni futni ha előtte
nem tanul meg járni ahhoz hogy jól
zongorázzunk előtte meg kell tanulnunk
az alapokat és sok 100 vagy akár 1000
órát kell gyakorolnunk ahhoz hogy ötös
szintre jussunk először el kell érnünk a
négyest előtte pedig a hármast nem lehet
szinteket kiugrani ez teljesen
egyértelmű például a küzdős sportokban
vagy a zenében hiába próbálunk meg
átugrani egy szintet nem fog működni ez
persze nem azt jelenti hogy nincsen rá
példa amikor valaki gyorsabban tanul meg
egy hangszeren játszani mint például az
átlag vagy ráérez egy küzdő sport
mozdulataira gyorsabban mint más de
mennyire vicces lenne ha valaki úgy
akarná egy nagy zenész képét eljátszani
hogy előtte nem fektett bele több 10000
órát is akár a gyakorlásba mert lehet
úgy tenni mintha nagy zenészek lennénk
lehet úgy öltözködni lehet akár beszélni
sőt egy koncertet is meghirdethetünk és
lehet hogy még a környezetünket is
meggyőzzük arról hogy mesterien
zongorázunk és egy egész koncertteremnyi
ember össze is gyűlik hogy meghallgasson
minket de abban a pillanatban hogy
rátesszük a kezünket a billentyűre az
első másodpercben kiderül hogy
szélhámosok vagyunk ez egy univerzális
és időtlen alapelv mindig is igaz volt
és mindig is igaz lesz függetlenül attól
hogy hol és milyen kultúrában élünk
ráadásul magától értetődő de ha ennyire
nyilvánvaló akkor miért kell róla
beszélnünk azért mert a korszelleme
minthogyha az ellenkezőéről próbálna
meggyőzni minket azt sugalja hogy
sikeres lehetsz igazi munka nélkül
gazdag lehetsz azonnal lefogyhatsz
fegyelem nélkül híres lehetsz valódi
tehetség nélkül például az alf generáció
egy jelentős része influencer akar lenni
mert azt látják hogy az influencerek
könnyű életet élnek jól szórakoznak és
látszólag nincs mögötte igazi munka csak
egyszerűen elmondják a véleményüket a
filmekben is egy gyakori motívum az hogy
a főszereplő igazi munka vagy valódi
áldozat nélkül csodálatos képességekkel
rendelkezik ezt az effektust úgy hívják
hogy mary se effektus mary seu egy
kitalált karakter akinek minden sikerül
minden próbálkozása összejön nincsen
igazi belső konfliktusa és mindenki
szereti őt például ilyen karakter ray
karaktere a star wars 7 epizódjában az
ébredő erőben ray egy poros bolygón él
ismeret a származása mégis az erőt olyan
szinten tudja használni ami megelőzi a
legnagyobb jedi mestereket is igazi
munkan nélkül igazi fegyelem nélkül
áldozatok nélkül birtokolja ezt a
képességet pedig a jedi lovagok élete
pont ezeket követeli meg ilyenkor a
filmek a fejünkkel játszanak el akarják
hitetni velünk hogy a különleges
teljesítmény elérhető fegyelem és munka
nélkül ez részben igaz a potenciált ami
bennünk van kapjuk van amire könnyebben
ráérzünk mint más sok de a kőkemény
munka alól nincs kiút magnus carson
hiába minden idők legnagyobb sakkozója ő
is napi 34 órát gyakorol steven curry
hiába minden idők legnagyobb három
pontos dobója minden nap 500-at dob ez
heti 3500 havi 15000 évente kb 180000
dobás ez azért hogy amikor a pályára lép
csúcsformában legyen ez a növekedés
alapelve nem lehet szinteket átugrani
munka fegyelem és é áldozat nélkül nincs
tartós eredmény ha érdekel ennek az
alapelvnek a gyakorlati alkalmazása és
szeretnéd megtudni hogyan építheted be a
mindennapjaidba legyen szó személyes
fejlődésről családi életről szakmai
előrelépésről vagy vállalkozásról akkor
csatlakozz a navigátor közösségéhez a
patreonon ott mélyebben belemegyünk abba
hogyan lehet ezt az alapelvet tudatosan
használni és valódi példákon keresztül
megmutatom hogyan működik a gyakorlatban
ráadásul egy támog közösség is vár rád
ahol együtt tanulhatunk és oszatjuk meg
a tapasztalatainkat kattints a patreon
linkre és csatlakozz hozzánk